you look amazing q so much I was going
for a hooker toddler bride one more time
hooker toddler bride hashtag thank you
can you get with a little spin I'll pull
up and down I love it's always Pride
season you're so spirited we got a talk
first of all ready or not why are you
excited about this film the movie is so
good I love games and then there's like
she's a bride and distress and just
feels very like summer camp and like fun
like horror
who doesn't love a white dress during
the summer a summer wedding
this shirt is my tribute to that summer
bride is simplified by tan lines and I
love it of course some drag race news we
know it's coming back for Season 12 plus
all stars
what are your thoughts are they cranking
out too much too soon no it's fine who
cares more drag queens you drag queens
make everything better look I'm at this
party the party got better right parties
are so much fun parties are better with
you around every party is good here it's
Hollywood what would it take for you to
get back into that universe and get back
with Mama oh yeah they won't invite me
on but like my all-stars was kind of a
star's born so I mean it's a more than
lateral move I'm doing alright I think
without it you certainly are and we will
get to that I have a question about that
but do you have interest in going back
to that universe would you make an
appearance if you were invited because
it's like I don't need to be judged at
doing like these fake competitions that
could like you know when real life is
kind of like the whole like story right
now for me I think no I don't want to
like jump through someone else's fake
hoops when I could be jumping through
the real hoops and actually be doing
stuff you know it doesn't make sense
like I'm not ungrateful but like at the
same time like done it you were
incredible in a star is born such an
amazing career moment for you I'm sure
Bradlee gaga they're both single and
fans really want them to get together
what are your thoughts on that well you
know I don't comment on my friends
personalized okay take yourself out of
it if you were me do you think that
there's a chance that they could
possibly would you want to see that oh
my gosh I want to see a sequel starring
me and shangela that's what I want to
see so Letta let him make a movie
together again what would that look like
that seemed book on me and chance was
just tearing it up yeah
sickening what else is next for you
what's on the list what am i doing next
I'm releasing a makeup line called cover
boy what can we expect everything
there's all this stuff that people want
to get when it's like put me in drag I'm
like this is all you need you need to
lash some glitter and a good lip that's
it the basics but you're doing it like
to the tenth degree I'm sure yeah it's
really good it's highly photoshopped if
you could if you could pick one
celebrity that you would get in cover
boy who would it be oh my god
it'd be a tie between Rihanna and Gaga
because I I love them both well
something tells me you've got Gaga's
number that's gonna be easy yeah I did
something with Rihanna like years ago
and but like the Gaga getting Gaga and
anything would be amazing but I love
Rihanna - cool congratulations cute
purse thing sorry I'm gonna eat you this
is like 7:30 at night my van we can beat
the don't worry all right bye see you
later